are you ready for hey you guys I'm Katie
Krause and this is Oscar Gracie and I'm
just gonna put it out there there are no
bigger Taylor Swift fans in the office
in the world than probably us and when
we think about end of your content we
kind of reflect on who we think have the
biggest impact and to us it was Taylor
Alison Swift no question Taylor Alison
Swift very necessary three names yeah
three names um so we want to just
dissect and discuss all the ways that
she sort of redefined herself this year
and all of our favorite moments from her
this year so I think we should just jump
right into it
she's given us so much this area so much
so much to love to be excited about
number one Taylor Swift getting into
politics I mean talk about impact and
again once you voted take a picture of
it tag me in your photo hashtag just
voted and I'll be looking for you
happy voting you guys literally the
second I saw the Instagram post I was
ready to run to the polls voter
registration went up over 60 thousand
voters in that twenty four hour window
your thoughts I mean she made me want to
unregister up to vote and then register
again just so like I say I registered to
vote because the Taylor Swift yeah
thanks
they reputation tour best one I've ever
been to best where you've ever been to
really yeah she broke the record for the
highest selling us tour I know we both
went to multiple days in the reputation
we went backstage we met Taylor a
reputation tour what do you make of that
from start to finish the first
nanosecond she went on that stage I knew
I was in for treats well you could tell
the detail that she put into this tour
to make it this epic experience and
that's what it is it really is so epic
and the snakes the sound effects of
visuals
oh Christ songs on the inside stays so
good she really snaps she snapped
[Music]
and she gave us this amazing gift of a
tour movie who did you see that comment
I thought it meets our music video
honestly I'm just happy we get to watch
the whole tour over and over and over
again because it really is that iconic
and I need it for the rest of my life
the other thing that I loved about
tailors the way in which she changed
record labels she was on big machine for
six years she's now with Republican
Universal she fought for other artists
in her deal she now has the rights to
all of her masters in because of this
deal I mean she's a businesswoman when
you think about it she really is and I'm
glad that she took this opportunity to
demonstrate how much she cares about the
business and for other artists in
general you know the fact that she used
she leveraged her own brand to make sure
other up-and-coming artists got their
fair share truly iconic Tara also made
awards show history at the AMAs she is
now the most decorated female am a
winner in history and even just that
night and all of her speeches to me were
so iconic and also so important listen
she's played me a full many a times the
past decade of Stan [ __ ] but now like
I'm on to you Taylor like I know you're
always coming free was that something up
her sleeve and she always wants the fans
bald so my leg is always glued tight
every time she comes on a stage I do
want to also bring up the Grammys she
was nominated for Best Pop Vocal album
uh-huh no nomination for album of the
Year reputation was the best-selling
album of 2018 not happy about we're not
happy about it
reputation is such a good album so
complex tells a story I mean this is the
stuff that the Academy should
acknowledge didn't this time we see
Taylor's evolution through this album we
see the story it should have been
nominated she's a Grammy darling she's
been nominated over 30 times she has ten
Grammy wins we also really saw her live
out this evolution she's really kept her
heart and her piece close to her mm-hmm
I do love that too and I think it makes
so much sense for this era that she's
you know just to herself she has her
happiness now she's really guarding that
yeah but I will say I do miss all those
beautiful photos were walking down the
streets of New York City
want to talk about what we want to see
from her next I like that this year she
sort of revisited her country roots to
an extent we saw her go back to the
Bluebird Cafe in April she released that
collaboration with Sugarland babe what
do you want to see from her next I do
want to see a little bit of that country
coming back when she is just with a
guitar with a piano her lyrics just come
out they shine yeah um so I would want
maybe a little bit of that red kind of
vibe where it's very singer/songwriter
the production can kind of be it can be
more Papa could be more country it could
be more bluegrass yeah I'm with you her
lyrics are some of my favorite lyrics in
the world I'm still obsessed with all
too well which is on the red album I
think it's my favorite song it is my
favorite song of all if you want to be
emotionally Iraq for like a month
listen to one I will say I want to
predict and I want to talk about what I
think she'll do next but here's the
thing about Taylor she always out does
what I think she should do mm-hmm and I
don't know how she keeps screen venting
herself but she does and I think with
especially with reputation I think that
I did not see that coming at all
now this snake the second let's make the
image Lydia's make promo teaser wow wow
that was something no that new music is
coming we don't know when but she's
teased it now twice once when she
announced that she was changing labels
and then once at the AMAs so we can't
wait to find out what it is I hope that
it's next year not in two years god I
think she the vibe that she's been like
throwing this little bread comes around
I feel like that's when we know it's
coming soon ish Taylor look what you
just made me do on that note you guys
we're gonna wrap up if you want to talk
about Taylor you can find us on Twitter
you can find us on Instagram you can
probably bet that a lot of our tweets
are about Taylor so you're always happy
to talk about um we'll see you next time
[Music]